seit einiger Zeit besteht der Wunsch bei
mir auch endlich mal Business Class zu
fliegen die Airline condor bietet seit
Sommer 2020 einmal täglich einen Flug
von Mallorca nach Düsseldorf im Airbus
A330 an eigentlich ein
Langstreckenflugzeug und die einzige
Möglichkeit Kurzstrecke in der Business
Class zu fliegen ich war sowieso auf
Mallorca und habe mir spontan einen
Rückflug in der Business Class gebucht
viel Spaß mit diesem Flugzeug Test aber
scheiß drauf und damit jo Leute was geht
ab und herzlich willkommen zum neuen
Video ich hoffe natürlich euch geht es
gut ich befinde mich hier gerade auf
Mallorca am Ballermann also zumindest da
unten ist der Ballermann eigentlich ist
halt gerade noch nicht so viel los liegt
daran weil wir 6:30 Uhr morgens haben da
hinten ist allerdings auch der Flughafen
und da geht es jetzt für mich wieder hin
denn ich fliege zurück nach Deutschland
sind noch ein bisschen müde sorry bin
gerade erst aufgestanden das ganze ist
ein bisschen besonders weil ich fliege
zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben wirkliche
Business Class natürlich ist es keine
Langstrecke Business Class ich werde ich
auch noch machen in drei Wochen da kommt
dann auch ein Video aber seit Ende 2020
Verkehr dreimal pro Tag ein Airbus A330
von Condor zwischen Düsseldorf und
Mallorca und dort gibt es quasi auf
einer Kurzstrecke eine Business Class
mit Essen mit zu Liegestühlen
Liegestühlen nee ich bin noch nicht so
drinnen in diesem Business Class gehen
aber das wird noch ja ich bin sehr
gespannt was mich erwartet wir gehen
auch vorher in die Lounge hier am
Mallorca Flughafen jetzt kann ich ja
auch mal hier ein bisschen flexen Moment
Ballermann Hotel hier ich habe mir jetzt
hier auch mal diese MX bestellt im
Platin damit komme ich nämlich in diese
ganzen Lounges rein und sag mir auch
noch Punkte und kann dann hoffentlich
dadurch viele Vorteile genießen ich bin
gespannt ich werde euch mal auch
irgendwie updaten ob sich die Karte für
mich lohnt kostet halt um die 700 € im
Jahr durch mein Business classic was ich
heute für Condor gebucht habe was
übrigens nicht mal 200 € gekostet hat
würde ich auch damit in diese Lounge
kommen aber ja ich habe gestern hier
noch am Ballermann ein bisschen geblockt
das blende ich euch jetzt noch ein und
dann geht's zum Flughafen so Leute was
geht ich bin hier gerade noch in Palma
unterwegs am Beach auf jeden Fall ganz
nice so irgendwie fehlen jetzt total
diese typischen Ballermann Touristen
wir sind nur so Rentner oh die haben
mich glaube ich verstanden okay das war
vielleicht ein bisschen eine Sache
wollte ich nur sagen ich kann ja voll
verstehen wenn man hier so in jungen
Jahren hinfährt und Party zu machen aber
so entspannt Urlaub zu machen gibt's
noch viel schönere Ziele na ja ich gehe
auf jeden Fall jetzt noch entspannt was
essen weil morgen früh geht hier mein
Flug und heute kann ich es nicht mehr
allzu sehr krachen lassen wobei einfach
mal alleine in Bierkönig rein warum
nicht also ich bin ja alleine unterwegs
na ja schauen wir mal was wir haben noch
so bringt und sorry das war gerade echt
gemein von mir was ich da gesagt habe
ich ein bisschen schlechtes Gewissen
irgendwie finde ich auch random das hier
natürlich auch in der Umgebung also ich
bin jetzt direkt beim Bierkönig und Mega
Park und so so Spielplätze sind so
einheimische spielen und direkt daneben
feiern so eine Millionen Deutsche
Zwillinge Schlagermusik irgendwie lustig
oder klar ist ja auch logisch ist ja
deren Heimat hier aber naja ich weiß
nicht ob ich hier so gerne wohnen wollen
würde wenn ich dann von hier komme
also das muss ich mir auf jeden Fall
entgehen lassen so jetzt gibt es auf
jeden Fall was zu essen und das
obligatorische local
traditionelles Essen habe ich mal
gespart wir sind ja eigentlich in
Deutschland
so jetzt aber schnell nach Hause oder ja
besser ist es okay Leute also hier ist
jetzt Mega Park da vorne und hier habe
ich jetzt auch die gängige Party und
eventszene gefunden und ob es mir glaubt
oder nicht ich sehe jetzt wirklich zum
ersten Mal in real life den MegaPark ich
war hier noch nie aber ich gehe auch
jetzt schnell wieder weggehen aber ich
bin halt alleine unterwegs deswegen
right Leute wieder im Hotel wir machen
uns jetzt auf dem Weg zum Flughafen an
die aufmerksamen Zuschauer von euch
vielleicht könnt Ihr sehen ich habe ein
neues Handy Case bzw eine neue
Handyhülle und die ist von Toras hat im
allgemeinen Leben als auch im
Reisealltag auf jeden Fall viele
Vorteile das zeige ich euch gleich noch
jetzt geht's allerdings erstmal los so
einmal noch zum Meer das ist auf jeden
Fall ziemlich unbeliebt hier alles aber
ist auch klar wir haben ja noch ziemlich
früh ich war noch nie so früher wach
aber scheiß drauf okay jetzt auch nicht
so besonders ne hat ja jeder Deutsche
schon mal gesehen wieder die aussieht
Airport Flughafen
[Musik]
okay für mich ging es dann ab durch den
Security Check und ich habe erstmal
geschaut von welchem Gate ich denn
Fliege die meisten Flieger von Mallorca
nach Deutschland zurück fliegen von
Terminal bzw den Gates C so auch meiner
und am Flughafen Mallorca gibt es
insgesamt vier salala Lounges von denen
ich mir eine aussuchen konnte die sind
aber auch super ausgeschildert und die
checken wir jetzt erstmal ab man muss ja
auch sagen der Flughafen in Palma ist
auf jeden Fall ziemlich groß deswegen
hoffe ich mal dass ich die auch schnell
finde weil ich muss jetzt erstmal
frühstücken so hier jetzt rechts über
mein MX Kreditkarte konnte ich mich dann
auch bei priority Pass anmelden dort
bekommt ihr dann unter anderem auch so
ein QR-Code als Ticket und mit diesem QR
Code kommt hier halt überall rein so
haben wir noch
ich hoffe das klappt jetzt auch so wie
ich es mir vorstelle
also hier ist ja wirklich gar nichts los
jetzt gibt's erstmal
so noch jetzt sogar mein Lieblingsbier
ist Träger Galizia das kann ja jetzt
nicht bringen oder
[Musik]
so also wir haben jetzt hier auf jeden
Fall ein Joghurt das geile ist hier ist
wirklich niemanden also ich bin fast
alleine bisschen Schokolade mit Brötchen
drin und Pizza Kaffee Orangensaft so
entspannt die frag mich warum ich das
nicht früher rausbekommen habe dass
sowas möglich ist erstmal hier noch ein
bisschen chillen und dann geht's gleich
zum Boarding man muss halt wirklich
sagen am Flughafen ist es wirklich
unfassbar voll gerade
komplett überfordert sind oder
irgendwelche Ballermann Touristen gerade
das aufgestanden sind und total
übermüdet oder noch einen Tee haben und
da ist hier zu chillen absoluter Game
Challenger Hammer
so Leute jetzt geht's im Flieger
[Musik]
seit wann sind diese Rolltreppen
eigentlich Links hier ist doch
Rechtsverkehr das finde ich irgendwie
ein bisschen verwirrend eingecheckt auf
geht's
[Musik]
angekommen im Flugzeug und auf meinem
Platz ich habe mir 5c reserviert
insgesamt gibt es 22 Plätze in der
Business Class ich blende euch hier auch
noch mal ein Foto ein die sind so ein
bisschen gestapelt aufgeteilt ich hatte
allerdings in direkten Fensterplatz
so Leute bin angekommen erste Eindruck
stabil
aber eins muss man sagen vom Babys ist
man ja auch nicht sicher da ich habe
wirklich zum ersten Mal auf einem
Business Class Platz hast muss ich
erstmal alles auschecken und ja man kann
das ganze ja in so einem Bett Form
bringen oder in die relax Form und es
gibt sogar eine sitzmassage das kann ich
auch echt krass nur aufgepasst dass man
sich die Beine nicht einklemmt ich hatte
Spaß was mir auch direkt auffällt die
Toilette ist viel größer ne das ist echt
krass
meine neuen Handyhülle auch einfach mal
abstellen
[Musik]
als Begrüßungsgetränk gab es zum ersten
Mal Orangensaft oder halt auch ein
Wasser ich habe mich in dem Fall für den
Orangensaft entschieden und dann haben
wir den Flughafen auch pünktlich um 9:15
Uhr morgens verlassen
Hauptsache hier gibt es einfach sogar so
eine Massagefunktion
automatisch auf
Fall lassen Sie Ihr gepäckte
[Musik]
wenn man dann die maximale Flughöhe
erreicht hat gibt es auch das Essen bzw
den Hauptgang den habe ich vorher schon
online gebucht ich habe mich dafür das
englische Frühstück entschieden war ganz
lecker ich habe schon besser
gefrühstückt aber gut wir sind immer
noch im Flugzeug trotzdem habe ich von
anderen Leuten gehört dass andere
Gerichte die Condor serviert wirklich
super lecker sind und ich beim nächsten
Mal mal was anderes ausprobieren soll
als Nachtisch gab es dann aber noch zwei
Brownies einen schokoladeigen und einen
mit Zitrone die waren echt super lecker
also davon hätte ich auch noch mehr
essen können
[Musik]
der Flug war dann super entspannt keine
Turbulenzen gar nichts super Ausblick
auch hier die Alpen ich habe viel aus
dem Fenster geguckt wenn ich aufs Handy
so muss sein für die dies interessiert
es gibt an Bord natürlich auch
Entertainment ihr könnt ganz viele
verschiedene Filme schauen ich bin da
ein bisschen durchs Menü gegangen ich
habe mir jetzt nichts reingezogen aber
man kann sich auch durchgehend die Stats
zum Flug anschauen mit Getränken wurde
ich zu bombardiert also man kann so viel
bestellen wie man möchte und zum
Abschluss gab es dann noch zwei leckere
Pralinen als kleines Abschiedsgeschenk
nach zwei Stunden Flug würde ich sagen
die waren auch super lecker vielen Dank
dafür und zaps ab da haben wir dann auch
schon am Ziel Düsseldorf Flughafen ja
das war der entspannteste Flug definitiv
meines Lebens okay Leute angekommen in
Düsseldorf waren richtig entspannter
Flug muss ich sagen also ich muss immer
so heißen Zukunft also so kann Reisen
auf jeden Fall unfassbar viel Spaß
machen das war so angenehm eine Sache
die mir aber aufgefallen ist so Leute
die Business Class fliegen die haben
noch mal ganz andere Probleme als so
normale Menschen also teilweise fragt
man sich da dicker was los bei euch eine
beschwert sich weil ihr die Klimaanlage
zu laut war der andere fand das Holz
Besteck nicht gut und wollte dann halt
anderes Besteck also da wird es bei mir
wirklich auch und die steware das
reagieren aber auch ganz gelassen darauf
als wäre das völlig normal also das hat
mich ein bisschen schockiert aber sonst
war alles super was geht Leute ich bin
mittlerweile wieder zu Hause angekommen
und bevor ich noch ein kleines Fazit zum
Flug abgebe wollte ich euch noch mal auf
den Sponsor vom heutigen Video
aufmerksam machen ich habe ja auch schon
einmal am Anfang auf die Toros apropos
sind series Hülle aufmerksam gemacht die
wirklich gerade fürs Reisen und aber
auch generell im alltäglichen Leben
einige Vorteile bietet gerade mit diesem
Klappbügel hier als Feature man kann
über sein Handy entspannt hinstellen das
Case ist außerdem super robust und euer
handy geht nicht kaputt das ist halt
auch super wenn man so eine Hülle hat ne
und das Case ist wireless charging
kompatibel das heißt ihr könnt ganz
entspannt weil es Laden müsst die Hülle
vorher nicht abnehmen ansonsten gibt's
von Toras auch noch ganz ganz viele
andere Höhlen ich blende Euch das hier
mal ein auf Amazon zum Beispiel vielen
Dank fürs spons Videos und wir kommen
jetzt zum Fazit an sich habe ich jetzt
nur 200 € für den Flug bezahlt die
Preise variieren immer liegen zwischen
180 und sogar bis zu 700 €. oneway das
Geld was ich jetzt ausgegeben habe im
Vergleich zu Leistung ist finde ich
ziemlich wenig deswegen kann ich nichts
negatives sagen der Flug war 1A
pünktlich super Service super
komfortabel ich bin noch am überlegen
für die Flugtest vielleicht auch so eine
bewertungsreihe einzuführen wie es bei
meinen zugtests immer mache könnt Ihr
sehr gerne mal einen Daumen nach oben da
lassen oder ist einfach in die
Kommentare schreiben ich würde auf jeden
Fall jederzeit wieder mit Condor
Business fliegen klar auf die Lounge
vorne weg war super das war wirklich ein
absolut entspanntes Reiseerlebnis und
ich freue mich umso mehr auf weitere
Reisen die ich dieses Jahr noch antreten
werde und mal schauen was da so noch
geht also ein absolute zehn von zehn
Leute vielen Dank fürs zuschauen
abonniert super gerne den Kanal und wir
sehen uns nächste Woche wieder haut rein
ciao